ladies and gentlemen welcome to screen
junkies movie fights powered by the
schmoe's new network now your host andy
signor
greetings screen junkies welcome back to
another episode of movie fights we hope
you had an awesome halloween we're here
to debate some fantastic topics and we
have some amazing panelists here today
again this is the show where real nerds
get in real fights over fake movies uh
so we've piled through the news we have
eight rounds of relevant stuff to fight
including uh marvel finally announced
the phase three lineup we're gonna
debate which one are we most excited for
we're gonna talk about who should be
captain marvel
uh which marvel villain should they
really bring back whoa we're also gonna
go off marv a little bit which uh if
they bring back the joker who should
play the joker holy crap really a bunch
of fun topics today it's going to be a
great show i want to thank obviously
we're here at the shmos no network
please go check out their other shows
they're uh housing us here and it's
they're wonderful partners we love doing
this show off in march mark ellis are so
great
um also i want to just warn everybody
there's a um uh youtube feature on the
bottom uh left
uh yes bottom screen no it's bottom
screen right uh you can click uh pick
the fight and you can watch and click
through any battle you want at any point
during the show so for whatever reason
we're not entertaining you you can move
on to the next one don't leave try a
different fight
great so let's get right into this i
want to meet the gladiators of today's
battle
first up uh you know him from the screen
ducky show and so many other awesome
things it's hal rednick
uh good to be here andy uh for halloween
i was the most popular character in
recent history jeff bridges from ripd oh
good one nice
next up really excited to have him on
the show you know him from belated media
he does the uh what if star wars was
good and so many other wonderful things
it's michael barody hey everybody thanks
for having me
next to him he's a screen junkie show
regular he's actually was on this week
wow two in a row congratulations thank
you uh he's been on a bunch amazing
commercial actor and fantastic funny
person mike carlson thank you so much
for uh letting me be here
you're quite well i mean hopefully you
won't let us down i don't know
all right
just so we all remember i will declare a
winner at the end of each round i'm
deducting points to your arguments based
on passion creativity
funniness
it's really all arbitrary to me sadly
today but i'm going to try and be as
objective as i can
so make sure you give good fight be nice
don't be mean and let's get to it in the
great words of ken
watanabe them fight
okay we're moving on to round one i'm
starting the clock
so obviously the big news marvel phase
three was announced i mean uh we all
know hopefully by now the movies captain
america civil war doctor strange
guardians of galaxy two thor ragnarok
black panther avenger affinity war part
1 captain marvel inhumans and avengers
infinity war part 2.
a lot of exciting stuff and i want to
open up the panel which one are we most
excited about how you're starting the
fight well um they uh i'm excited about
all of them but there's only one right
answer here it's captain america civil
war i mean that is the first one if that
one goes wrong um the things are not
going to fall into place the movies are
gonna it's gonna be a derailed train
also civil war is such an epic storyline
that's one of the best comics in recent
memory um
seeing all the avengers go at it tearing
each other apart
the other movies are unknown quantities
like we don't know um is it gonna be uh
is is gonna be an origin story or where
are they gonna pick up from civil war is
an awesome story and uh it's gonna set
the tone
michael what's your thoughts
um i'm i'm of the camp guardians of the
galaxy 2 is my
my top pick i uh i i feel with the rest
of the marvel cinematic universe we've
been going a little more uh not not dark
gritty dc but we've been trying to
ground things a little more and the
guardians films uh i mean guardians this
summer was just the fun swashbuckling
space movie that i think everybody was
like oh my gosh i didn't realize how
much i've needed this
needed this and uh to be coming back
there are so many unknowns uh as hal
articulated but i find that as a very
positive attribute that
allows us to be going a lot of different
and new places and exploring and seeing
things in vastly different ways with
that off-kilter humor that james gunn is
going to bring and the entire cast yeah
love it mike what's your thoughts uh my
thoughts are that the black panther is
gonna be cool and it's because this is a
new thing we're going to a different
country it's a different part of the
marvel universe these movies are going
to be good we know that like we we got
it we got the creative teams we know
these guys are going to hit it out of
the park what's exciting to me is that
we're going to a new corner of the
marvel universe it's a different type of
movie he's a king he's a king superhero
in a technological part of africa it's
going to be amazing that's what i think
great all right so
yeah let's open it up so yeah cite each
other why why do you uh yeah um so uh
captain america civil war it's gonna set
the tone the same way that iron man set
the tone for the entire uh just marvel
um epoch that we're a part of right now
and
taking down or mentioning the gritty
tone being a problem too dark and gritty
i mean look at captain america winter
soldier man that
introduced some real life like uh spying
and like post 9 11 world that we live in
and it turned out to be a great element
in that movie so i'm looking forward to
more of that and seeing the avengers
torn apart that's uh i can't wait
i think i think that's an it's a fun
angle well no it's not a fun angle that
that's where i take issue is uh we've
gotten to a point where now a lot of our
movies are trying to be
more mature which i can totally
appreciate um but
we kind of are getting
lost in the the
overarching thematics of a movie we have
uh nick fury and captain america
discussing the privacy versus security
issue a little too overtly for my liking
in winter soldier and i feel like we
might be seeing a little more of that
and we've obviously seen uh just from
the clips that have been teased out for
age of ultron we see tony stark and um
cap more or less discussing what might
be the thrust of civil war
i love the over the over-the-top
larger-than-life action in uh all these
all of the marvel movies but the gritty
real action from winter soldier was
mind-blowing those are some of the best
sequences in all of the recent marvel
canon i want to throw back to you i mean
you're black panther
how do you feel about black panther's
going to be introduced and apparently
dawn that that the costume for the first
time in civil war i mean does that sway
you at all that look i like i like the
idea that we're going to see him first i
think from when i was at the press
conference on tuesday and he came out
the guy playing uh black panther and
they did a whole bit like who's he going
to join
chadwick boseman thank you and he was
like i think i'm staying neutral on this
so i have a feeling in the movie
to be making yes but civil war everyone
like acts like civil war is like the
greatest crossover of all time like go
back and read it it's just like this
kind of like
thinly veiled 911 parable like a couple
years later and we're gonna finally get
that in 2016. we're gonna get a movie
about the patriot act in 2016. well and
we're and we're going to be getting it
from a very different uh perspective
because it's not going to be about
secret identities but we've already seen
um well civil war also handles something
that i think we've i don't know i've
talked about with a lot of my friends
like after a movie hey what happens with
all that death and destruction is there
uh is there any payback is anyone held
accountable and civil war also handles
that
a very real cool issue in the superhero
universe who like superman uh
when you go to dc he should have to uh
pay for everyone's insurance policies uh
for destroying metropolis yeah
reparations on superman do we well i
think we're gonna get that in batman vs
superman as well it's clearly going to
now become a new thread in these
superhero movies is oh the destruction
yeah we actually want that though no we
don't want that because why would we
want an hour of like bodies being taken
out of the rubble this is depressing
these are fantasies we didn't say that
it's not real we don't need to see
people like people going through
paperwork and loved ones being told that
their their friends and uh family have
died in a horrible building accident
you're right let's just act like it
didn't happen yes let's do that because
that's superheroes it would be very
strange to be following all the tertiary
characters who
are like oh my life has been torn
asunder because of these terrorists no
no you're absolutely right that we don't
want it to be a grim death march but we
but acknowledging it a little bit like
wow the destruction we're picking up the
pieces uh let's do a little speculation
here because i feel like we know where
civil war is headed yeah i get that but
where do we think guardians 2 is going
to go
why is that going to make it exciting
and also what how is black panther going
to be good in a standalone because i
feel like they're already going to drop
some hints about him in ultron it's
clear they showed claw we suspect that's
andy circus and it's clear that probably
ultron gets the vibranium like they're
clearly dropping little nuggets that are
leading us to black panther and then
clearly civil war is gonna give us black
panther so where do you think it goes
beyond that and then where do you think
guardians 2 goes i sort of want to hear
your sides well i think i think
guardians 2 is obviously going to be
filling in some of the gaps with uh
everything leading us to the infinity
gauntlet uh more so i feel then age of
ultron will because that's going to be
very much on earth whereas now we're
we're exploring the further realms of
the galaxy probably introducing new
aspects that will allow us to tie in
other things
if they need to
personally i'd i'd prefer it to be more
isolated but i understand they need to
be linking things up because people like
to be like oh hey
that but you just wanted to go on their
space adventure not connected is that
where you think it's gonna go i don't i
don't think it's gonna go that way but i
would not be upset were it to be a more
isolated a little jaunt because clearly
thanos is there thanos is there i mean
uh drax says like
it's it's thanos that he's really after
at the tail end of uh the first film so
we have to assume that's at least
slight slightly the trajectory
um and i think that'll put us in a very
fun place probably
i mean i have to assume
with
uh infinity wars being split it's just
going to be this megaton
collision course of everybody and i'm
assuming guardians are involved yeah
they're probably not going to overdo
thanos and guardians too because he is
uh you know the antagonist for infinity
wars so there'll probably be a little
drop of thanos and especially because uh
uh in guardians the first guardians we
got the most thanos we've ever seen mike
black panther i want to wrap this up and
move on to our next one
i like the idea that i think it's going
to be sort of an isolated movie because
it's going to take its time because it's
the first one in the series it's going
to take its time building up a different
section of the marvel universe and then
once that thing is established then
we're going to have a lot of fun
bringing it into it but i don't know i
don't see that many clear things other
than the fact like ultron is made of
vibranium cap shield is made of
vibranium which are manufactured in
wakanda i don't see huge ties uh that
are obvious to me that might uh fold
into infinity war mike is wakanda one of
those countries that has ebola
uh
no okay no not all right i gotta declare
a winner this is tough because i wanna
see them all to be perfectly honest but
my two points i'm going to give two
points this round because i think i do
like you made a good point i don't want
to see much origin stories in some of
these other movies which they could
become easily i think civil war is a fun
story i think the setting is great and i
do like the accountability but i also
gotta give mike a point because i agree
i don't wanna really see the bodies
being pulled out of the buildings
that's not really exciting and i think
uh you know there black panther is a
really exciting thing uh your point
about the fantasy films was a good so
i'm gonna give you both points uh to
clear winner on that round sorry michael
next round
uh hey guys
the nature of the beast all right round
two
uh
avengers infinity war is gonna be split
into two parts is this a good idea or a
bad idea
uh
i'd like to ask our panelists and let's
start with michael it's a very solid
idea i think i think purely based on
already what we've kind of discussed how
we're we've got a lot of different
stories converging
and really
they've
been converging since
we started to bring the avengers
together
this is clearly something that is going
to require a lot of moving gears and
cogs uh all
converging appropriately and if we rush
through that we're going to wind up just
with a sort of
cluttered series of action sequences
which won't amount to us getting to
enjoy
seeing these various worlds collide as i
assume they will be uh
so i feel it is a
necessary thing for us to be breaking
the movie um
or the the larger story yeah just to
keep us not rushing out into two parts
very good point michael we need time i
think this is a great idea we need time
to see all the moments we want to see
yeah iron man and rocket raccoon i said
it on the show screen junkie show
earlier this week they're going to be
quipping they're going to be trading
barbs we want a lot of it we want at
least 10 to 15 minutes of just that
paul rudd and howard the duck
think about that think about that paul's
just dead panning and howard so that
they're trying to go to the club i want
a 10-minute scene about that i know it
doesn't make sense as far as infinity
war but i want it i want all these
moments to get as much time as possible
agents of shield i want them in it i
want the people on the marvel show i
want all the netflix people a daredevil
luke cage i want any other netflix show
i want kevin spacey in it i want
everyone in this movie and it needs six
hours for that
do you want them in part one or part two
i want them in both i want everybody in
both movies i don't care i want more i
want more more more how uh what you just
described as a bloated mess
okay
you know i i do uh want to see uh iron
man and uh rocket uh uh going back and
forth robert county but um man 10
minutes of that i mean de niro and
pacino weren't even on screen together
for 10 minutes and heat uh
that's like wow um but didn't you want
to see them for more than you want 10
minutes
you know um less is more sometimes less
is more so i'm saying uh but wait were
you the same person who argued that
godzilla wasn't in the movie long enough
well he's the star of the movie here
there's a lot of mouths of you we're
talking about one scene of quipping fair
okay okay so um
i'm excited for these two movies i'm
gonna see them either way but i think uh
let's put aside this three-hour lincoln
mindset of movie making like one after
another and make a streamlined
film and how many films do they have
leading up to this movie they can't do
the dirty work they can't do the heavy
lifting in guardians 2 in captain marvel
in cap civil war
let's uh let's add it up and then boom
have one major film uh two films by the
way they only do that when that's going
to be the end of a franchise that's like
a franchise ender uh
harry potter
twilight and
those were not the best examples there's
a lot of bloat there gosh worst case
scenario it becomes a hobbit
we don't want a hobbit do you want to
hop it up in that mix i don't want to
hob it up in this mix but it's marvel
we're talking about it's not this is not
another thing where it's just a cash
grab and they've cut the movie in half
just to sell more tickets yeah disney
doesn't care about money they love money
regarding the hobbit though if we can be
getting denny's items
last november and it was the worst meal
i've ever had i am not joking infinity
waffles guys infinity that's a good idea
but anyway back to the argument well i
guess the argument though is should it
be in two parts like is there a
standalone film in each of these films
or do we care and can we not is that is
the rule if it's going to be continued
and there's too long of a story rather
than make a six hour movie we're gonna
make two three hour movies i'm fine uh
if it's one movie as long as that movie
is six and a half hours long i will sit
there i will love it i will love every
second of it well i'd poop myself with
regards to uh it being the end of a uh
like a capper i feel in many ways a lot
of a lot of our actors contracts are
expiring on this film so it seems like
that is what's going to be happening and
phase three is introducing a bunch of
new heroes so we're getting a like fresh
reset while also being introduced to
like hey here's the next wave of
everybody that you're going to be stoked
on and i i i want to rush us through
this not to cut it off because it's a
good debate and people are mad at me but
i think
the reason i'm gonna go with mike on
this is because i feel like they're
making a movie where it's the only
chance we're gonna get all these people
in one movie together whether it's part
one or part two they're clearly all the
contracts everything's falling along and
i think if there's one moment to see
them all together if we gotta cut it up
into two pieces to get them interacting
over the course of two movies in one
story i think that's probably
a little bit better than why they split
up twilight into the book or even the
movie those movies because we don't know
what the story is it could be you know
the size of the you know game of thrones
to in our there's no exact thing they're
basing this off of so i wanna i wanna
just call it on mike and i think it's a
good i think at the other day we do want
to see rocket and iron man we do want to
see peter quill and iron man we want to
see all these people interacting with
all right hopefully the more time we get
uh the better okay moving on to
round three
and i'm sorry i didn't call out i'm just
going awkwardly back i want to thank our
viewer submission aaron evans who asked
that first question on twitter thank you
this is another fan submission uh snow
dog on twitter asked snow dogs very
underrated movie right oh yeah uh yeah
who should play captain marvel carol
danvers um captain marvel is a little
there's a dcn marvel backstory to
captain marvel there's a lot of you know
stuff to it but they've committed this
is like the carol danvers version um uh
in the marvel cinematic universe she's
really their biggest super power also
kevin figgy said um who do we want to
see here uh play michael you're mike
carlson you are up first michael michael
sorry it's okay uh the most obvious
choice is my favorite choice katie
sackoff from battlestar galactica friend
of the schmoes on here often well she's
great she's spunky she's cool uh she
will embody this character you need
somebody with that kind of charisma that
toughness that can embody because this
character is a pilot she's also flies
and goes into space so you want somebody
who can do all of that you want somebody
who can sort of
encapsulate
all of those things at once and she can
do this i am confident of it from her
work i can see that hal
um i'm kind of going off the board for
an unusual choice but she had a
startling directorial debut this year
one of the best indies of the year um
in a world i'm going with lake bell i
think lake bell um i mean she
looks like uh she's like she
looks like a tough chick but she's also
got a soft side to her i think um she
will really bring kind of a modern feel
that you were talking about with katie
sackoff like someone who can you know
has a sense of humor but um
she a really modern uh cool version that
i'd like to see her uh
play captain marvel
michael i mean i'd have to say katie
sackoff is the obvious choice to go in a
completely different direction just just
for the hell of it i'm not gonna get the
point but let's say
let's say emma watson let's just let's
go let's go younger let's see uh
somebody who clearly has a handle on
um
i mean
she's she's magnetic we've seen that in
perks of being a wallflower we've seen
that as uh her in hermione and like have
we seen that though like have we seen
her range yet i mean like bling ring and
or toughness i guess blingering is a
good example yeah it's we're seeing that
she's able to play against the the
convention of oh we thought she might
just be locked into nice smart girl we
see that she can do more than that and i
feel that she's somebody who is
looking to stretch herself not only that
carol uh like the the character of
captain marvel is somebody and this is
kind of going outside of like the scope
of movies but is really
showing herself as an uh assertive like
powerful uh
female figure and with the he for she
movement that emma watson is backing
she's like she is the face of that right
now and i feel that would be a very
powerful
uh just like
all empowering and i'm sure she's dying
to sign up for another seven picture
contract
but then the other answer
if we want to just go joke answer
beyonce drop mike billions of dollars oh
man i could i could get behind that i
could also find that um but i don't feel
emma watson brings the gravitas that you
would need for captain marvel is a
colonel she's a high-ranking military
official yeah unless you were going to
do straight up origin story and then
throw some emma watson inside i know you
i know you don't like origin stories but
i mean this we don't we've been seeing
time and time again they've been
flipping the script the fact that ultron
is being developed by tony stark and not
uh and not like in the ant-man
versus him yeah
there we go
so it's it's not out of the realm of
possibility it's just a necessity of
storytelling but i
uh i think lake bell just brings that
edge that you need like i could i don't
know she's like belle is something
mysterious
i feel sad i feel she's too flighty
personally with lake belle but i i
thought she was
she was entertaining in a world but i
didn't feel like she was going to
scare me at any point like i feel i feel
either sackoff or emma watson can
actually emma watson can scare you i she
she can be pretty imposing well watch
battlestar galactic the episode where
where uh starbuck is fighting liadama
they're just having it out after seasons
of this tension and back and forth and
romance and like the toughness and the
sweetness is all in that performance and
you also believe that she's the best
fighter pilot on that ship all that's i
mean do you want to see her play
practically the same role again yes a
good point yes i do
she's great at it why would we want to
see her do something that she's not
great at i mean one of the things that
marvel does really well is just giving
us exciting casting choice i feel like
you know she'd be solid she'd be solid i
don't know lake bell i think is a more
exciting choice i gotta that's a tough
one on that one i'm gonna call it on
mike though just because i'm not seeing
the lake bell but i i want to give you a
half a point because i feel like you're
right in that i like marvel taking those
chances and if they or the director
believe that she can do it kudos and
that's a good point that's worthy of it
but at the end of the day i kind of want
to see katie sackoff do it again
battlestar's not on and i feel like
she's she can be aged from her character
and battle star a little bit and take it
a little further so another point for
mike and half a point for her uh this is
scored like golf right yeah so i'm
really killing it
right great
all right moving on to round four
which avenger should retire first
obviously we are running out of
contracts things are going to start
winding down we've even brought that up
in our first uh our second round which
one do we want to see go first if we if
we had to do it either in an epic way or
just because we don't like them uh how i
go to you first um i'm gonna go with
thor chris hemsworth i want him to uh
retire uh or lose the hammer and uh thor
fades into obscurity and then
let's follow the comic route and get a
female thor to grab the hammer and then
you would have a female thor and captain
marvel two strong female protagonists uh
as part of the avengers and man the cool
power dynamic because those are like the
those would be like the two most
powerful characters in that universe
thor is a god captain marvel has the
powers of um kevin feige was saying it's
their superman more or less i think that
just that would be did he say that to
just try and one up all the news that
finally dc is doing a wonder woman the
first do we feel like that was on
purpose to that he really was just
making that hard but no well our
superhero is stronger i mean i think a
lot of it is engineered to undercut uh
pull the rug out from uh dc but um man i
to me that would be such a cool
storyline and then plus if thor lost the
hammer and they were like battling
thanos and like man i wish we had a thor
and then boom a new thor a rose
it's pretty exciting michael
hawkeye
like what has he been doing at all just
he he's he's had a cameo in thor the
first film he was next to useless in
avengers
he's there's there's no time
to
thoroughly develop him especially when
you're adding two new
characters and their buddies in age of
ultron
he's just kind of taken up space so
let's just
casually cast him aside and maybe later
he can he can be revisited as some other
character joss whedon has said it's
hawkeye and hulk have a big part in this
movie that would be amazing and ultron
so maybe we'll find out more about uh
maybe we'll find out more about him in
this in this one uh mike what do you
think uh i'm saying iron man because
first of all he tried to retire in the
third one the end of the third movie he
wants to retire in this ultron he screws
it up he's the guy who creates ultron so
obviously tony stark needs to retire
like like he's he's obviously the oldest
bike 15 to 20 years it's he's getting up
there do we want like 65 year old tony
stark don't we want why not now you want
to see him with rocket now that's what
i'm saying do you want tony stark then
just to stay in the movies as not iron
man yes i do i'll i'll have tony hanging
around he's obviously maybe running
shield he's running some sort of a
business that's helping to protect
everything but as far as him being iron
man it's probably time to step down in
the next five years maybe at the end of
the next avengers movie
interesting what do you guys think
hearing each other's debates it'd be
kind of cool to see old tony stark being
like i'm too old for this but i could
still wear the suit and you know maybe
his drinking problem comes back and he's
just like this the grizzled veteran he's
like and he becomes mad with power and
you know in civil war you know you have
that dynamic of him verse cap and some
of those elements of like hanging on and
the old guard could really come into
play and like i'm okay in like if in
phase you know 10 if tony like 75 and he
needs to put the suit back on like a
dark knight returns type yeah where he's
like i gotta get back out there one more
time that's great but i do think he
needs to let it go for you know 20 years
or so
uh what do we think of hawkeye do we i
love hawkeye hawkeye we have barely
scratched the surface on hawkeye i want
him to hang around if
for no other reason then maybe we'll get
a solo movie because i want that baby
wow you're going to complete i want a
solo i want
you also want a six and a half hour yes
i want i want one of these movies every
week also like i just want to put that
out there right if hawkeye and black
widow tell us anything it's that anyone
can be an avenger yeah i need to know
what is the hawkeye what makes that
interesting you're losing me a little
bit i love hawkeye and if if you read
his latest comic book written by matt
fraction which is amazing it's hawkeye
and he is just in an apartment building
and he fights an armenian gang and he
has a dog named pizza dog and it's the
greatest comic book it's so much fun
he's such like a regular dude who's
trying to grapple with being an avenger
because all these people are gods and
he's just a dude yeah so like he's sort
of a loser but he's really fun because
he's trying hard he tries to help the
people in his building and it's this
awesome fun adventure but
it's it's we want to see that on the
screen
as a regular person
truth be told it has not translated to
the screen jeremy renner is taking up
space
trolled in the first one like i don't
that's a strange thing to do to a new
character is immediately go oh yeah he's
a good guy but he's a mind controlled
he's mind controlled immediately true so
the audience is like well i don't know
who this guy is it just strikes me as
very strange that we're going to have a
character who's been around for several
movies and then we're introducing two
new characters but then we're also like
hey why don't we learn a little bit
about this guy who's just been in the
shadows that's what those solo movies
will be for it's to really learn about
him and what his life is like
how well i mean you do need him there
for civil war and civil war you need uh
as
you need to have all these characters
going you also needed spider-man for
civil wars but we uh oh man talk about a
dream i would love that i mean sony
please make it happen
probably not happening
okay so
that those are all really fantastic
debates um i gotta say though
man i'm having a tough i don't i don't
want to see hawkeye so i you get a point
for that but
just personal preference probably a
little bit but i think honestly you each
got points because you made a good point
of uh uh um uh saying that because
because he was brain brushed we didn't
really get to learn him so um and i i do
like this idea of how of thor losing the
hammer and and the female thor lifting
up amidst the battle that could be a
great sequence i think honestly all
three of these are good and that seems
like i'm being a terrible judge but i'm
giving all three of you points
it's like this round never happened
exactly well you all earned it it was a
good one thank you michael wasn't that
your first point yeah but negated by
your point so
you know feeling great
and all it's the tabulation at the end
that really matters time for round five
uh doesn't make sense uh kevin rockland
actually sent us an email to tips at
screenjunkies.com where he asked which
marvel villain should appear in phase
three thank you for writing kevin we do
read our emails and we were fascinated
by that question because i think it's a
good one because there really haven't
been strong villains in these movies
it's all about the heroes with maybe
obviously the exception of loki um so
now we have a whole new phase how do we
introduce a cool new villain who do we
want to see and we're going to start
with you michael uh it's not so much a
new villain so i apologize for answering
in an indirect way hey guys what
happened to red skull that's my question
because we've we ended captain america
with him just like
phasing off
and we've had no explanation so far i
feel like
there's a larger component in play that
i would like to see come to light and it
doesn't seem like we'll be seeing it in
either civil wars age of ultron or even
infinity wars well you're gonna have two
movies to
you gotta fit yourself there was a rumor
going around i remember at the time that
and uh winner soldier robert redford was
going to be red skull was what the twist
was like oh he somehow d whatever but um
would we have liked that would you have
liked that i wouldn't have liked that i
i
but i'm i'm curious because he obviously
now has a celestial connection going on
as it was tesseract energy that sent him
into space
um there there's
something fun that can be
pulled from this unknown
otherworldliness that i feel would make
a very fun return for that character um
especially since
i mean so much has changed and we we
don't know what he's been up to so i
feel like that's i think it's a fair
it's a fair fair answer i like that and
i we haven't really known where he's
going mike carlson what do you think
excuse me i want modoc modoc is uh a
character obviously from marvel universe
who is a gigantic head he was created by
jack kirby he's probably like if he were
real let's say he's like 20 feet high
he's mostly a head tiny little arms tiny
little legs it's like no other character
we've seen easter island like easter
yeah a little bit like easter island
those are more tall than uh than wide
but this is going to be we have not seen
like a really fantastical character that
almost breaks the physics of what we
know is like reality now and that will
do this uh he's got he's kind of like
krang right he's a little bit like crank
only he's like is if krang started grew
big and he was like too too big for his
body but he was like kind of sticking
out that's what uh modoc would look like
modoc has sometimes been treated as a
comedy character i'm okay with either
there was an episode of the iron man
cartoon where he disguised himself as a
giant baby i'm i think something like
that would be very fun it would be a
nice little break from the uh i feel
like they did that on with the mandarin
though in in iron man 3. didn't they and
that sort of ruined it a little bit well
they they he would still be modoc he's
not going to be revealed to be some sort
of an english character actor so as long
as that's gonna happen i'm okay though
if we have a giant modoc with a little
bonnet on and people like oh look at
that giant-headed baby that's very like
that's i want something like that i want
something weird i want to do you want
the absurdest piece from marvel i want
and which movie do you see him appearing
all of them
you had me and then
all of them how what do you think i mean
i think we're i think we're getting
plenty of weird with guardians i mean i
want weirder baby okay uh i i mean uh
you know too much of a good thing uh i
want to see kingpin kingpin is the
street level mob boss that is going to
wreak havoc in the city and kingpin
would be a great avenue to suck in
punisher man if you wanted a way to get
spider-man in there that'd be great and
uh also daredevil and they're saying
that they're gonna fold in the marvel tv
shows um
but uh
and uh kingpin um is going to be played
i believe by vincent d'onofrio uh in uh
the
um in uh daredevil uh so that would be
just really cool to see and would bring
some of that gritty action that we saw
in winter soldier i loved that i loved
it you did love that what do you guys
think of kingpin do you want to see him
again
from michael clark duncan's uh portrayal
uh yeah
the late great michael clark duncan yes
uh i love the kingpin i want to see him
but he you know he's a normal human
we've seen normal human villains before
he doesn't have a gigantic eddie it's a
big head
but he does not have a gigantic he has a
fair yeah i mean i i think uh thanos
more than fills the void of fantastical
villain um kingpin would give us an
awesome uh counterbalance to that on
earth yeah we we i mean arguing on your
behalf we we don't have the
human sort of masterminded character we
we we had like robert redford as like
hale hydra but it wasn't it was more of
like an ideology an ideology like evil
that was existing rather than just like
corruption and just kind of ruthless so
i i can understand that michael you know
what i'm going to do right now i'm
giving you a soul point on this round
you know why because i agree with you
gave hal a good point which hal didn't
come up with but i also think it's a
fair point of why don't we have red
skull he's such an iconic villain to
captain america who's become such an
important part of this universe how do
we bring them back and they have to do
it in a cool way that robert redford way
wouldn't have been so i'm glad you
didn't like that but i don't mind if i
said that there was a mo dom also he had
like a lady modoc that could oh so could
there be like a floating head family yes
and he's made others if you had sold me
if you had sold me and where he goes
realistically i would have maybe went on
board but i gotta give michael i gotta
give michael let's do it he did he gave
a good argument there you're on the
board fairly well so good work
um let's go to round six
now there's a deadline actually parts an
article um that the um
they're trying to make captain america
winter soldier and oscar movie um
they're putting out the you know the
press releases and they're trying to get
out there uh for the russos the director
best picture all these things um so the
question then comes should captain
america winter soldier be nominated for
a best picture do we think we've we've
gotten to a point where a superhero
movie could get the numb um and we're
gonna lead with mike carlson what do you
think uh i don't think it should be
nominated because it in my my opinion
about the oscars like it's for a
different thing captain america does not
need the oscars like we've already like
it's it's the one of the most popular
movies of the year it's made all the
money oscar should be for something
that's like a very uh well-made piece of
art that maybe the general public
doesn't always see i understand titanic
wins and sometimes they have popular
films but it i don't think it
necessarily is the best movie of the
year and i also don't think it needs the
bump because the oscars is a bunch of
movies that i am forced to see because
they're going to be in the oscars and
then i'm i'm uh shown a bunch of stuff i
might not have gone to the movies
normally i mean the argument came
originally with dark knight which didn't
get the slot which everyone seems to
think it should have do you do we think
that should have been it does winter
soldier on a better league
let's keep the conversation about what's
your thoughts um yeah is it the best
picture of the year no is it one of the
10 best movies of the year hell yes i
mean it's like it's just another money
grab by the academy i don't like that
there are so many movies nominated by
the way because uh it's like oh we can't
make up our minds so let's do little
league baseball and give everybody a
trophy screw that but we live in that
reality so since there are 10 movies
possibly being nominated usually like
it's eight or nine uh
let's include winter soldier it's one of
the best movies one of the most
entertaining movies it succeeds on so
many levels it's a transcendent
superhero movie and because of that yeah
let's celebrate that i mean the academy
has this problem where it can't nominate
an excellent comedy or an excellent
action or superhero movie
that's that's bs
i don't know pardon me but uh sorry mr
spielberg but lincoln was a snooze fest
okay um i started watching that with my
mom she was visiting and um we got it on
itunes i went into my room and took a
nap okay sue me okay sorry it was more
of like a play than a movie wasn't it
yeah um this was a great movie this
celebrates the medium of film michael
it does have its uh attractiveness in
the fact that it's discussing a sort of
topical
uh
discussion of privacy versus security as
i've gone over before it does have that
throwback of the espionage that
everybody seems to be a big fan of
technically yeah it can get
sound mixing sound editing it can
probably even
get visual well no it probably won't get
visual effects but i don't see it being
best picture material in that there are
going to be
movies that will introduce the idea of
security and privacy even like
better than captain ameri i don't i
don't think that any but let's be clear
we're not the the question is should it
be nominated well i think we it's fair
to say it's not the best picture but out
of ten roles do we think it's fair to be
the top ten nominations no i don't think
so because it for it to be nominated
there need to be
many attributes in play i don't think
well while performances are good i don't
think there's standout performances that
make me be like oh that moved me or uh
the screenwriting was so strong that it
really made me reconsider uh where i
stand on in this larger debate i don't
think i don't think
i i think a best picture nomination
should be making me
uh
you know why does avatar get a best
picture nomination and winner soldier
can't this is a great piece of escapism
that's a good point mike carlson i would
say that avatar should not have been
nominated
so that would be what i would say uh uh
uh but
here's what i think i think that captain
america two is like a delicious chalupa
from taco bell and i don't mean that as
an insult because i love chalupas i eat
a couple a week and it's what i would
like to eat more than something like a
fancy kale salad something more
nutritious something really delicious i
am a chalupa fan but the oscars is for
those fancy kale salads and it's not
it's but do we want that yes i don't
think it needs to be exclusionary and i
do feel there's a i want to exclude
things i i feel there's i feel there's a
place for movies like that i just don't
feel personal guys choice awards on
spike tv
it should sweep the guy's choice awards
i am on record of saying that i i would
no i would think there's a well i mean
it's going to be up against guardians
and dawn of the planet of the apes um by
the way dawn i think should be nominated
as uh as well um i think dawn more so
than captain america personally um i
think you know
for the most part you're right mike in
that um it is the place of kale salads
but hey let's make it a full meal and
let's have an awesome sunday for dessert
you know um
this is a transcendent action film this
is uh it was kind of an afterthought and
then it was like wow it surprised
everyone became one of the best marvel
films um in recent memory uh i i think
it earned its place yeah i mean i
ultimately got to go with the other day
it's like i feel like you're making a
point of i think we do need to make the
academy rethink the star wars and things
that haven't gotten in the past i think
it slowly is with the avatars but avatar
shouldn't have either but um i think
whether each
out of all these arguments i think your
your strongest point to me was there's
10 movies there's 10 movies it's
definitely up there um and i do agree
the less lincoln's the better just
because why do we need to keep rewarding
these snorefest movies that
just because danielle lewis deserved the
best actor you know nomination doesn't
mean it deserves the best picture so i'm
gonna give it to hal on this round
um and i like that you brought up the
avatar because you brought it up i
almost gave you a point for the chalupa
but i hate cal salad so i don't want
that to keep me
um
it could have been anything round seven
so uh joao martin on twitter asked uh
and this is coming uh this is now we're
leaving marvel territory so bear with us
um but he asked a very fascinating
question who should play joker in a
potential batman solo film um we did uh
this question just was interesting to me
i wanted to throw it in there thanks for
submitting um but obviously there is
going to be a solo batman movie with ben
affleck we need to then obviously joker
is too iconic to not bring back at some
point we got to do it at one one time or
another how do we want to do this who
should be it do they need to channel
heath ledger at all are we completely
ignoring that has he made do we have to
go a little bit there um i'd love to
hear your thoughts and sorry who ended
up last round we're starting with
uh how no i'm sorry starting with uh
michael
uh i'm gonna
go with a
maybe weird throwback-y one
michael keaton
i feel wow
for two reasons one
if if any if any of you have seen
birdman
he is
like if you ever were to doubt the man
had acting shops
hot damn the man has acting chops see
birdman it's fantastic it's good um
so you can you can see that he can
channel
varying degrees of energy and intensity
also there's the
wonderful oh yeah wasn't he the first
batman as far as you know our are more
current uh realm and then you've got the
aspect of i mean
beetlejuice was wonderful and so he can
capture that zaniness so there's a wide
spectrum that he can be playing to and i
feel like we also i don't i don't feel
it should be a uh heath ledger like nod
in any way i feel like it should be his
own thing and i think taking it that
slightly older angle on joker would be
very interesting and engaging and we
haven't seen anything like that before
michael i've already given you a point
because you blew my mind fantastic
answer you could still win another point
if you win this debate uh but let's keep
going mike carlson what do you think i
am going to go with uh adam driver
from girls and the upcoming star wars
film um because we've seen a hundred
versions of the joker we've seen him as
a charming kind of crazy guy we've seen
him as a real ruthless killer we've seen
the heath ledger we've seen the jack
nicholson i want a young guy who's
charismatic and explosive to do his own
take i'm not even sure exactly what he
would do with it i just know that this
guy has a bunch of charisma and he's
also very scary sometimes and that's
what we need for the joker i'm not
exactly sure what he would do with it
but that's why i'm excited about it
because i want a fresh take on this well
when is he scared when has adam driver
been scary when he's uh having dirty
talk with lina dunham uh he yes he first
of all yes he is i mean there is
something there is something inherently
scary about that it's not some dance
scary sexual things to people yes he has
a lot of scary sexual things he makes a
woman like like crawl on the ground and
he's like intense and terrifying in a
different way and this is where i leave
you he like really has um uh jason
bateman a little concerned when they're
driving in a car so i think you know
that it's horrifying
i like adam driver but i got a hedge
until i see him in star wars and do
something that is out of his indy
darling persona because he has been like
he's he's an indie darling michael
keaton you said oh yeah and then there's
the thought that he was the first batman
that's not an oh yeah that's stunt
casting like
that's insane that's almost pretty much
a disqualifier it's so weird that would
be so weird that he was the first batman
then he played joker um
completely different franchises they are
completely different franchise their
reboots and everything but it's still um
i don't know it'd be that's just too
weird right
but isn't that what joker is it's flip
joker is all about flipping
things on their head and nothing would
be better casting than flipping i mean
making back exactly
your child batman has now gone psychotic
yeah joker loves watching rome burn and
uh he is who are you picking out um i'm
gonna go with joaquin phoenix i mean
that guy just immerses himself i mean he
like he is such a chameleon roll after
roll and um he could channel his own
particular version of crazy like joaquin
finna if
a lot of people um ding the master for
being like a little bit long and
pointless but the performances were out
of control and walking phoenix the way
he loses himself in there and plays that
damaged goods person so do you see him
doing a cause i like that choice it's a
little obvious but it's like do you see
him doing it similar to how he did it
he's gonna find his own way on doing
that he's gonna find his own particular
way i don't think anyone should try to
mimic
anyone ever really unless you're uh
unless it's like a biopic um yeah i
think that'd be but there is a lazy
choice i wanna ask that to everybody
because i find that interesting it's
like there was an anarchist way that he
portrayed it where it's like it was
pretty perfect it was pretty great and
it's not to say that we could we're
stealing from heath but it's like which
is such an iconic way to do that the
joker in a way in today's world in a
realism way we can't borrow from that at
all like we where he needs to do his own
completely thing or are we annoyed that
it's like yeah that was a little too
much like heath did i think give it like
10 years and then you can start taking
from heath it's just so like it's just
like six years when people are just
gonna be like well i can clearly see
he's going wow he's licking his lips and
he's doing the whole thing like and
you're gonna go well i'm just thinking
of heath ledger the whole time i wanna
be i mean you're gonna think it
regardless even if he's not licking his
lips right i think mark hamill sometimes
because mark hamill's one of my favorite
jokers i'm a big caesar romero fan as
well romero's great even um uh jack
nicholson was good which is his borrowed
from cesar romero a lot um whatever
whoever we pick i think we could all
agree we need a new joker because this
halloween the glut of heath leather
ledger jokers and that we've had since
the dark knight it's too much it's too
much we've seen too many heath ledger
jokers at this point on halloween hot
topic has made too much money off of
that character i mean mind-blowing one
of my favorite um cinematic villains of
all time heath ledger's joker but
too many halloween costumes
all right i'm gonna call it uh i'm gonna
give michael another point for winning
that debate i think you've made a good
battle i'm still blown away because i
actually it is stunt casting but to me
it's it's kind of cool stunt casting but
i mean you have a point for the
halloween costume because that was fun
as well thanks all right we're moving on
to our final round
um so uh this just came in the news seth
rogen is gonna be uh playing steve
wozniak and danny boyle's steve jobs
flick with christian bale playing steve
jobs um which brings up the question one
i want to know do we like that um can
can he pull off uh oh i'm sorry that is
our main fight i'm reading the sub fight
let's start there can seth rogen pull
off the dramatic rules of question but
then i will also get into whose other
best comedic you know what other comedic
uh actors have pulled off these dramatic
roles but let's start with seth rogen
can he pull off this role of a dramatic
role i'm in mike carlson let's start
with you uh yeah absolutely uh i always
like to look at who's making the film as
well because that person obviously has a
big role to play in helping an actor
like pull off any role and danny boyle
is great seth rogen i think has been in
in certain movies you know funny people
and has shown that like he doesn't have
to be you know making a poop joke or a i
don't want to say the swear word but a
swear word related joke you know uh so i
think that yeah in a move when you go
with danny boyle movie yeah most people
are going to be great in it you take
seth rogen who is a very talented guy of
course he's going to do a great job
uh how we think yeah agreed you had his
running mate uh in wolf of wall street
uh you know if he's running mate
were they running for something yes um
yeah and
it's uh it's not that much of a stretch
for him i think he can definitely do it
he's shown chops um i uh 100 agree that
seth rogen uh can pull this off michael
most of apatow's camp is very capable of
doing dramatic i mean they all
showed that in funny people 50 50 is
another example where he's very i mean
he plays the funnier angle of it but
he's still able to be somber and sober
and dramatic when he needs to be he also
brings a fair amount of heart to that um
so this was a very exciting fight yeah
because we all agree so let's bring it
down to we we like seth so we think he
can pull us off and i think the pearl's
probably a little silly anyway steve
wozniak they would you'd think you'd if
it's any if josh gads take it they'll
probably he's a little he was the comic
relief exactly
so um let's take it to the sub fight
then who do we who is the best comedic
actor in a dramatic what is the best you
know community actor in a dramatic role
what do we what do we think we'll go
back to you mike who do you think um i'm
gonna say bill murray uh and take your
pick broken flowers lost in translation
i love the life aquatic of steve zizu i
think he is so sad in that movie and so
like so affecting and like there's you
just like
you feel for him the whole time he's
just like he never says like oh i'm in
pain but you can feel the whole movie
and like the time he's at the end he's
in this in the the ship and the
underwater and that cigar rose song is
playing it i cry every single time it's
amazing
uh how love murray i worship at his
altar but murray is always murray bill
murray does his bill murray thing and
i'll watch that all day long but when
you're talking about a comedic actor in
a dramatic role let's talk about a
comedic actor that did a role that was
so shocking so against type that it
turned people against him and had his
fans being like what the hell are you
doing but movie purists being like wow
you did something different and you
killed it adam sandler and punch drunk
love
i'm a huge paul thomas anderson fan and
that film that sandler performance was a
total 180. that and it's something we've
never seen from him since because the
true sandman fans um were so against it
and were so shocked by it but um as an
actor like his levels of
uh yelling of
yelling
the way he destroyed that bathroom
came out
and no and and there and there were
subtle so many subtle tones as well
it was a good role michael uh i'd go
with robin williams and
again a take your pick sort of situation
world's greatest dad awakenings uh dead
poets society like
he's
he's an
excellent uh individual who brings a a a
sadness to
some of these roles but the humanity as
well there there's so many in all of the
uh these dramatic roles that he takes
you see so many levels to his characters
which is something that i feel i mean
all of them exemplify murray going off
of that yeah murray tends to hover and
there's a lot more internalized which
i'm not going to fault for and i
definitely do agree on like life aquatic
for that but
i feel world's greatest dad is
a
just
soul crushing
uh performance from him uh especially in
light of more current events
um
but the the
the fact that he's
kind of lost and listless and he makes
such a terrible decision that he then
has to kind of deal with and it more or
less cripples him um as he grapples with
that i just find i just find he he was a
a comedic actor who then was challenging
himself in very different ways with each
of his roles i would argue that williams
became more of a dramatic actor he was
he was better as um this pseudo-comedy
uh uh uh
a dramedy actor than being a straight-up
comedian afterwards i mean he shifted
gears later in his career like all the
films you just there's so many that
there is so many he was no longer it's a
good it's a good point but do you guys
think i won't stop being a comedian uh i
would argue look to the crazy ones a
television show where he was
holistically supposed to be like he was
the funny man and sarah michelle gellar
geller was the straight man do we really
want to dishonor the man's memory by
bringing up the crazy ones
and i don't want to say anything i love
robin williams and uh i i miss the hell
out of him he wasn't the problem in the
crazy ones though he did he did his job
he was he killed it for what he was
given i mean he ripped the hell out of
that he rips the hell out of everything
but but robin williams the thing is
watchability in a film that might not be
as good if he's in a movie that's not
quite as good i don't think i'm as
engaged as i would be with bill murray
bill murray can be in any single movie
and you're still engaged you're still
interested in this guy and as far as
adam sandler adam sandler is the king of
doing the same thing every time even in
that paul thomas anderson movie which is
about
he the idea for that film was we're
gonna explore all these weird damaged
people from adam sandler's movies and
see uh where this guy's pain comes from
so yes he's doing a great job also you
could have you could cast a dog as the
lead in a paul thomas anderson movie and
it's going to be amazing
so i mean i love that movie i love i
love adam sandler too i'm just saying
high praise paul thomas anderson brings
out the best in people he's great he's
wonderful i gotta call it and i i just
can't call it between murray and
williams i feel like they're just those
are the two best choices sandler was
great in that film but you can't
you did your best but you just can't put
them up those two so i'm going to give
you both points thank you for those uh
valid battle and by doing that i
actually believe
i've created a tie
hal and mike are tied this is our first
tie so we're going to go have to go
quickly
tiebreaker whoa so michael unfortunately
you're out but you were close you were
four and four at the end you were one
away do i get to help you you will tell
me points you will help me make the
winner how about that is that fair all
right let's do this so we asked on
twitter uh you guys don't know this this
is speed we're gonna each get a chance
and we're right on we'll go are there
multiple questions just one jonathan
jones on twitter asked what's the most
overrated movie of the last decade since
2000
go
uh avatar
how um the most
the most overrated movie um i like his
quick answer how you gotta go quick uh
man of steel
ooh all right go let's hear it well i
avatar was nominated for best picture
it's the highest grossing film of all
time not adjusted for inflation but the
highest grossing film of all time
clearly like people love this movie more
people love this movie oh they're making
four more movies making four movies
they're making a whole avatar land down
at disney world and that took the place
of like a star wars land or a marvel
land out here and now at least at least
avatar uh did something great which was
whisk us away in one of the most
visually appealing worlds we've ever
been i'm not talking about pandora
pandora was great and the unobtainium oh
when will they obtain it
but um man of steel was such a misfire
it was such a dour tone um it crammed
too much stuff into one movie and it was
really a rocky way for dc to get it its
new phase off and running and uh i hear
a lot of people love it they're a lot i
mean our good friend mark andrake always
is a man of steel i don't trust anything
mark andrenko says hell uh yeah um man
of steel i don't think is widely
accepted as the misstep it yeah who do
we think more audience members liked
more a man of steel or avatar because
that's really going to help make
advertising i think avatar i think the
box office proves that more people like
there was return the people kept going
back it's because uh of the visual
smorgasbord that it was people were like
oh i got to see avatar well i got to
hear your argument a man of steel
because give me give me the more
specifics of why that film is overrated
not why avatar's not oh man of steel is
overrated because it tried to uh the
first superman franchise uh with
christopher reeves um told the man of
steel story in two films uh superman one
and superman two this crammed zod and
everything into one movie and the origin
story and the story on krypton it was
way too much it was
but why did people like it
why did people like it that's what we're
asking here it's overrated people uh
just accepted oh it's superman i like it
i think that on rotten tomatoes you can
go and i'm not gonna check this right
now i'm just gonna say it as a fact on
tomatoes avatar is a higher tomato meter
than man of steel which means literally
it is overrated that's literally the
definition it's rated too high and i
think man of steel i know is sitting at
like 56 or 60. all right we gotta wrap
that up you both got your points michael
we can confer but i gotta say i'm gonna
go with avatar definitely i think it was
a close one there and i'm with you man
still but i think man of steel divided
audiences and avatar for some reason is
still just going strong avatar was a
weird juggernaut the imax i think or
just imax 3d it was like the first one
that was like look dazzling effect so
amazing job mike carlson your first show
and you end up finally tal is still
unable to clinch a victory you are very
close
all of you did a fantastic job
when he said avatar i was like no that's
a good choice yeah i
saw like the deflation of pope you're
like well uh that's the speed around he
gotta you both have the shot all right
guys thank you for watching tell us what
you thought in the comments below if
you're watching on youtube please
obviously use those um and if you're
listening on itunes please go rate
subscribe find us there if you're not um
tell us what you want us to fight about
in either place twitter youtube itunes
if we pick your submission which we did
a lot of these one of these random lucky
individuals will get a free screen
junkies t-shirt so thanks for submitting
also i want to thank the shmozno network
thank you so much once again for having
us here in the afterbuzz studios always
a blast doing this
again don't forget to click the bottom
on the left to click through the fights
i want to thank our panelists uh hal
rudnick uh your twitter at hal rudnick
thanks for coming here anything else
you'd like to plug uh screen junkies
show uh yeah i'll see you guys in
cyberspace michael barady your twitter
as at belated media anything else you'd
like to please check out his youtube
channel fantastic yeah just check out
the youtube channel there are various
things there that you might enjoy link
will be in the description below and
then famous commercial actor mike
carlson thank you so much your twitter
fat carlson p-h-a-t carlson anything
else you'd like to tell the viewers uh
if anyone lives in los angeles at the
ucb theater uh november 7th i'm doing a
show at midnight called the orbiting
bear a pleasure cruise to inner space so
go to
go there and say ucbtheater.com
junkies movie fights sent you tell mike
carlson and we'll find a way to get you
a shirt yes but only the first person to
do that yeah one person how's that mike
is that a cool place that's very cool
thank you all right good uh hal knows
how hard i am to give those away so
that's why he's impressed all right
thanks again everybody i want to thank
after buzz shmoes no uh we're wrapping
this up please subscribe for more movie
fights and tell us what you want to see
thank you we will be here next sunday
and have a great day
bye
bye
every podcast we put on youtube comes
with this kick-ass graphic listing all
the topics your favorite screen junkies
podcasters are talking about if you
click the topics you can skip around and
choose your own podcast battle royale go
ahead try them all
if you haven't already subscribe to
screen junkies on youtube to join us for
future fights or if you prefer to listen
on itunes click the logo to download an
audio version lastly please support our
friends at the shmo's known network for
more awesome shows